okay nothing to see here the media
providing the White House some support
and down playing the findings from the
FBI and energy Department that covid
likely leaked from a lab in China
no surprise here Jake that Republicans
on Capitol Hill are seizing on this new
reporting bad energy Department no bio
Labs until you finish building your
electric car charging stations
stay in your lane they're saying the
confidence is low in it they're coming
to a conclusion based on incomplete
intelligence FBI
Democrats on the media are doing
beijing's bidding
you still have liberals in the media in
the Biden Administration acting like a
defense lawyer for the Chinese
Communists covering up for them
apologize for for apologizing for them
excusing them acting like we can turn
the page when millions of Americans lost
loved ones lost businesses lost jobs and
we have not yet held China accountable
for all of that harm and the FBI is
pushing back against criticism of the
lab League conclusion director
Christopher Ray defending the bureau's
findings in an interview with Brett
Baird that's going to air tonight watch
here
the FBI has for quite some time now
assessed that the origins of the
pandemic are most likely a potential lab
incident in Wuhan let me step back for a
second you know the FBI has folks agents
professionals analysts virologists
microbiologists
Etc who Focus specifically on the
dangers of biological threats and Dr
fauci weighed in call for number one
here
um
we must all keep an open mind as to all
possibilities need to be entertained you
think we'll ever know how the pandemic
originated
might not it very well might not we may
not ever know that's unfortunate but
that's the possibility that we might not
ever know I mean don't we know Greg no
Dana we will never know I use this a lot
with my wife at home when she says like
who is that woman you were with and I go
I don't know what you're talking about
but in truth we will never know it's not
a defense it's more like it's wishful
thinking I mean if you were on the hook
for nine million dead you want to hope
that perhaps we'll never know because
what we might find out is that you know
did leak from a lab in which the United
States was involved with that's the kind
of thing that you know was brought up
here a couple years ago and and it was
laughed at and now here now it's like
it's good it's a plurality it's reached
to plurality the thing I've noticed is
that when it was decided that it was
naturally derived the scramble was on to
find out what it was that the wet Market
was it a Pangolin was it a bat bat soup
whatever who was there what happened
then when the man made uh Origins become
more and more plausible to the point
where yeah it's so obvious that it's
true now it's we'll never know so how
convenient is that everybody was looking
for the origins until you found the
origin and then it's like yeah you know
what we're going to say with this there
was a guy from The Daily Show I thought
did a pretty decent thing about talking
about how this was a almost like a team
sport in the sense that like you know
it's got to be a wet Market no it's got
to be the lab why is this now a team
sport like why is like why do you have
to be married to this the only reason
why you would be married to one or the
other is to escape
ability rokana this is call for number
three Harold listen to him I think you
might agree with him but also I'm just
curious why more Democrats don't watch
here
as you know I'm a defender of the first
amendment of free speech and I think it
was wrong to try to censor the folks who
were arguing that it was a accidental
leaked from a lab at the very least we
know it's a plausible theory if the
department of energy has put this out
Harold I agree with him uh I've said I
think he's one of the more sensible and
thoughtful uh people in Congress
Democrat or Republican and and I don't
think of censor anybody you can disagree
with him and put forward the facts to
refute it
on the FBI matter and I'm interested in
watching watching Brett tonight because
the full interview will be on there he
basically said we've been investigating
this for a long time which I was pleased
to hear and FBI didn't have to tell us
everything like they didn't let us know
when all the leads they had on that
double murder suspect in Idaho even when
we were we were all saying why don't
they tell us more why aren't they doing
well I'm glad they were maybe they've
done more here uh you have to think the
administration I give them some credit
for maybe being clever here and I I I
condition what may be with you guys but
I think it could be clever in this
standpoint why would you let four
different agencies come out with two
different positions some may say cynical
you may cynically say well that's
political they want to make sure they're
covered two it could be that they're
being really clever about this the the
department of energy and FBI says look
we believe that this thing could have
been a lab leak and other agencies two
agencies said well we don't we don't
think that could be the case they both
have low levels of confidence I hope we
continue to investigate this not from
the standpoint of being able to blame a
party or another but to figure out how
and why we had to suffer like we
suffered uh as a nation like I give I
give president Trump a lot of credit
when he encouraged NATO to spend more in
defense some Democrats jumped on him
NATO's not spending more in defense
they're investing more in their defense
not as much as we'd like but they're
investing more than they were before so
I like these kind of efforts here and
and I'm hopeful that instead of playing
a blame game uh that we will figure out
uh how we prevent this we should all be
in the problem the FBI's confidence was
medium level and the department of
energy was low I thought they were both
low no one's medium one's low come on
come on
all right first of all I don't think
anything is clever about our government
saying you know some I said maybe you
said okay low confidence here's the
bottom line did somebody eat a bat or
was this engineered to be transmitted to
us as humans I think we all agree it was
engineered in a lab where we gave money
to the echo Alliance and the Echo Health
Alliance for gain of function all right
they're covering their asses I said this
yesterday because they don't want any
discussion of that but this is a problem
problem for Biden and what fauci comes
out this guy's a scientist a virologist
he comes out and says we may never know
hogwash we may never know they're
virologists they are scientists they
should know the truth is it's better to
say we may never know because a million
Americans died and they're dizzying and
going back and forth the United States
has to decouple from China and this is
just another piece of the of the puzzle
we had the balloon a few weeks ago now
covet is back China wouldn't let us in
there they were very opaque even though
I think gray said today the Chinese
government was doing their best to
obfuscate and thwart answers the bottom
line is China is not someone that we
want to work with or necessarily defend
there's no point in it and I don't think
anybody's being clevered we've suffered
enough our kids have suffered enough uh
businesses have gone under people have
been depressed people have died it's
horrible no more Dilly dallying get to
the bottom of it and move on all right
Jesse wrap it up she knew everything and
now you'll never know fauci had all the
answers but now he's keeping an open
mind
well it turns out fauci's lab partner
killed a million Americans and he's like
well my lab partner may have killed a
lot of people here
and we might have the same Alibi but
don't listen to any of the
whistleblowers and don't listen to any
of the scientists who disagree with me I
mean this guy has a million dead
Americans potentially on his hands but
he's keeping an open mind about that
good job Fouch can't throw can't grow
and I'm not going to say what else you
can't do
Colbert is basically the Court Jester
for Pfizer remember he was supposed to
make the vaccines go down easy and
there's a Smoking Gun document Fouche is
like emailing him hey can you do a
little skit for us to make everybody get
boosted so he was doing this and why was
he doing this because his company is
owned by was it Viacom Paramount do you
know how much money
their parent company has at stake in
China we're talking billions and
billions of dollars these parent
companies they censor their own content
in China you don't think they censor
their own content in the United States
as well of course they do Dana
and that's me told yes and I say that
with a
without anything
without a high level of confidence never
and I say that with a high level all
right I went on Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now